it's time for a taste of babble at
brezza a new restaurant is coming a new
restaurant experience i have to say is
coming to the uncommons and brezza's
nicole brusson and jason russell are
here to show us what we can expect
welcome to our kitchen well thank you
for having us i'd rather be at the
kitchen at bresson
so tell us exactly what is babel a taste
of babo you know this is this is really
exciting for us um you know both chef
and i lived in italy before and in new
york
and you know one of the most iconic
restaurants that came out of there
especially with italian restaurants in
new york city was babo um and she also
happened to work with a number of
different chefs there so this is a
collaboration it's also a reunion
we're bringing in five different chefs
from the mar the battalion posse honest
days and we're all coming together a
seven course dinner um our beverage
director mikas katona put together
wonderful wine pairings from all
different regions in italy um so it's
just really you know like what we do
every night we bring people together we
entertain and and we enjoy ourselves and
we break bread we break bread well tell
us about the menu i know right now she's
making the two-minute calamari stew
right yes so we're making a two-minute
calamari you cook calamari really two
ways you cook it really fast and rapid
or slow and low this is the the fast and
rapid kind uh mario name that's the
sicilian lifeguard because it has all
those beautiful flavors of sicily you've
got the sweetness the currants the the
gorgeous uh gaeta olives we have these
caper berries which is actually the the
fruit of a caper bush it adds a nice
like solidity to it and believe it or
not
sicily is more closer to morocco than it
is to
milan so mario would describe this dish
as just having an arabic kiss to the
calamari which is really nice i love
that a little geography lesson as well
thank you um what else is on the menu
while you prepare the the stew we have
one of jason's favorites which is a mint
love letter with merguez sausage we have
a classic
spaghetti botarga which is one of my
favorites
we're finishing with a beautiful
gorgeous giant ten pound beef shank
that's going to be carved table side and
that's going to be soaked inside
[Laughter]
parmesan risotto
now this is an experience so how can
people enjoy it and and have the
experience so uh you can buy tickets on
eventbrite um and also on our instagram
you can find a link to that uh brazili
okay there we go and the finished
product oh my gosh that looks amazing oh
and it smells so good you guys now you
guys are located right at in green
valley
um so no resorts world right on las
vegas in the district right next to
barza zoo okay and then our future
restaurant will be on commons amari
up at durango in 215. there we go thank
you guys so much i'm ready to taste that
thanks